all references to climate change except
one which makes fighting climate change
seem like a really bad thing have been
removed as of 12 p.m. eastern time on
friday january twentieth at eleven
fifty-nine a.m. eastern time the obama
white house website at a long list of
information about the threat of climate
change the steps the federal government
had taken under president obama to fight
it and at noon the instant that Donald
Trump took office the page was gone as
well as any mention of climate change or
global warming except for referring to
President Obama's Climate Action Plan as
harmful unnecessary and something that
the Trump administration would get us
out of preventing climate change is
harmful and unnecessary what has to
happen for Trump to change his position
on that Trump Tower falling into the
ocean first America first during his
inauguration speech an old anti-semitic
swamp slogan Trump asked not to use it
by the anti-defamation league and then
now the only place that climate change
is mentioned on the Trump White House
website is negative of course scientists
and professors around the country we're
downloading and REE hosting all of that
climate change data some people Pat said
oh it's paranoid because nothing's going
to change about all this under Donald
Trump within seconds of Donald Trump
being inaugurated everything about
climate change gone from the White House
website that's exactly right I guess he
wasn't persuaded by the meeting that he
had with Al Gore and ivanka trump down
transition I mean we don't really know
too much about his position on climate
change he's made some hilarious comments
about it but the issue here is that
Republicans are back in control and of
course they're going to defer to the
interests of big oil and be cool yeah I
mean we we the entire all of his
references to climate changes of hoax
created by the Chinese what does Trump
really think I don't know he got a lot
of mileage from that but ultimately what
Pat is pointing out is what matters
which is look at who has been appointed
to work for Donald Trump and look at
some of the other little bits and pieces
that are on the Trump website as for
example the following quote for too long
we've been held back by burdensome
regulations on our energy
industry president Trump is committed to
eliminating harmful and unnecessary
policies such as the climate action plan
and the waters of the u.s. rules this
lifting these restrictions will greatly
help American workers yeah get those
coal miners their jobs back Cole makes
no sense it's laughable to try to
revitalize the coal industry as Donald
Trump claims to want to do the world is
laughing at us and by the way not that
this is something to brag about for
Obama domestic oil production grew more
under President Obama than under any
prior president in US history it's
embarrassing that this is what the
Donald Trump administration is doing
meanwhile India's rebuilding their
energy infrastructure from the ground up
around clean energy sources China like I
told you last week is closing down plans
for 80 to 100 coal plants and investing
360 billion dollars in clean energy and
we're going backwards in trying to
revitalize coal well at least this was
the only topic that the White House
website took down from its side LGBT
stuff as well I believe so yeah right
its civil rights as well yes no not not
the only thing at all and very very
disturbing and we're going to keep
following it and it's going to get bad
and we need independent media at this
time I've been harping about it for
months it has never been more clear and
I hope you'll join us as a member at
david pakman.com slash membership